Miss Rebecca Howe Sam Malone Sam Rebecca
Howe how do you do
uh
to you Kirstie Alley has died following
her battle with cancer and in the wake
of her death Hollywood's reacting it
never feels very real to me as soon as I
walk off a set off of a movie or off
this show or any show that I do I feel
like wow am I lucky
shortly after news broke of the actress
dying at age 71 her former co-stars
chimed in like John Travolta who starred
alongside Kirsty in the look who's
talking movies
no I'm talking to here myself probably
thinks we're going to end up together
the actor writes quote Kirsty was one of
the most special relationships I've ever
had I love you Kirsty I know we will see
each other again I felt like
I had been with John a long time and
John was charming and I thought
well maybe we can be Charming together
Jamie Lee Curtis who appeared with
Kirsty on Ryan Murphy's scream Queens
praised her work writing in part she was
a great comic foil and scream queens and
a beautiful mama bear in her very real
life I went on the match game and Jamie
Lee was on the panel and I wasn't really
allowed you weren't really allowed to
talk to each other so because you had to
make sure that there was no tricky stuff
going on you know but I do remember I
was walking down the hall and she said
hi and I was like
um yeah I have the same feeling now
Christie's cheers co-stars are also
sharing their memories with the late
actress the days that I had here at
cheers were there are the best days of
my life in a statement to E.T Kelsey
Grammer said I always believed grief for
a public figure is a private matter but
I will say I loved her while Rhea
Perlman called Kirsty a unique and
wonderful person quote we became friends
Almost instantly when she joined the
cast of Cheers I've never met anyone
remotely like her I feel so thankful to
have known her I'm going to miss her
very very much the biggest thinking
behind it was that
uh uh it was cheers I definitely would
not do any other TV series
I love that show I love the writing the
actors are all they're great I think
they're hysterical as for Ted Danson he
revealed to E.T he was just on a plane
watching this old episode of Cheers you
know I'm a plumber and I'm not very good
with words and uh
oh I want to just forget it no no no no
why don't you just sit here and relax
and you think about that question you
want to pop and uh I'll give us some
champagne so that we can celebrate the
answer
Ted says Kirsty was truly brilliant in
it her ability to play a woman on the
verge of a nervous breakdown was both
moving and hysterically funny she made
me laugh 30 years ago when she shot that
scene and she made me laugh today just
as hard I feel like it was one of the
biggest honors of my life to be able to
work beside him and I'm really happy
that he got this star and I'm more happy
that he got it four years after I got
mine I love him
the actor adds I am so sad and so
grateful for all the time she made me
laugh I send my love to her children as
they well know their mother had a heart
of gold I will miss her